sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana bitmex the
og crypto derivatives platform and the
best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys anna welcome back to the lay
ohio plan show so as you know this
podcast is sponsored by the
cryptocurrency exchange bitmex so a huge
shout out and a massive thank you to
bitmex because on this show we talk
about all the things you're sort of not
allowed to speak about we talk about
authoritarianism censorship freedom and
of course bitcoin so without bitmex we
wouldn't be able to bring you such
valuable and really crucial information
during the times that we're living in so
joining me today we are joined with
trainee priest broadcaster and
conservative commentator calvin robinson
calvin welcome to the show my pleasure
to be here thanks for the invitation
yeah my pleasure it's great to meet you
we only recently connected um but i love
everything that you're doing online and
we're going to get into all of that but
for those who don't know who you are
just give us a brief background oh i
hate that question because i don't know
where to go
i i
present on gb news
i used to do a lot of talk radio stuff i
write in the telegraph the daily mail
occasionally the express and the times
about
issues that i think are important in our
society such as education faith and
culture let's start with the faith part
because something pretty interesting
came out a couple of weeks ago um and
you're a trainee priest but from what i
understood somebody i think it was the
was it the bishop of edmonton
stopped you or blocked you from being
ordained so can you just give us some
more information about it yeah it's a
challenging one because
they
the bishops have all the authority there
are no procedures to follow there are no
policies so you can't call them out for
example in an employment tribunal or
anything like that but what's happened
is there's been a sustained campaign
against me by the bishop of edmonton who
doesn't like my political views
not my christian views not my theology
but my political views the bishop of
london has been the person that he's
been complaining to consistently and she
is the person that's ultimately
ultimately responsible for a person like
me
and
has therefore said we're not going to
take it forward and this is after you
know
four or five years of discernment plus
two years uh reading theology in oxford
uh all paid for by parishioners you know
little doris in the pews has paid 20
grand to send me to college uh and at
the end of it they've said no but what
i've just learned is that
they've never planned on sending me into
a parish you know i did a subject access
request so we all have a right to see
any data about us that's held by a
public body
and i saw emails going all the way back
to before i even started training
suggesting that they did not like my
views and did not want to see me
ordained so
the church of england doesn't want to
see you ordained because they don't
agree with your political view so what
what's so bad about your political cause
tell me one example is calvin does not
believe in institutional racism i mean
that's a very broad statement to make
but what i've said is that you know when
the cred report came out
the cred the sewell report didn't find
any evidence of institutional racism but
found very very
it found many elements of racial
disparities and it put forward
suggestions on how to solve them ideas
actions going forward to help make this
country a better place i was like yeah
let's follow those actions let you know
let's stamp out racism we all want to do
that
but people are campaigning say actually
well it doesn't say that racism is
institutional so we can't follow the
advice like it's that word they get
stuck on which words institutions so you
so you basically you don't think that
the uk is institutionally racist no i
think there are many elements of racism
and there are many nasty racist people
and those people need to be held to
account but that doesn't make the entire
country racist i can't think of any
country that's less racist than the uk
it's one of the best places in the world
to live as an ethnic minority we have
protections in the equalities act you
know we have equality in law we can do
whatever we like if we work hard enough
but i think people use institutional
racism as an excuse it's all the system
is against me i've been held back
because of the color of my skin i can't
get anywhere why should i bother it's
like no get your head down work harder
you'll make something of your life and
these priests are white
yeah always white middle-class or
metropolitan liberal elite types you're
saying no you're wrong on this issue of
race calvin in fact i've sat down with
the bishop of london and she said look
as a white woman i can tell you the
church is institutionally racist i'm
like well that's not my lived experience
surely your whole
your whole stick is that you want to
listen to the lived experiences of
ethnic minorities why not mine is it
because it doesn't meet the narrative is
it because it doesn't align with your
views is it true that you really want to
listen to us or is it just you want to
listen to the ones that you can pat on
the shoulder so you're a good black boy
you know you're you're going along with
the party line i think it's a new form
of racism actually i think that's racist
to say to you so you're obviously mixed
let's just make that clear for those
that don't know so you're mom dad so my
mom's white my dad's black okay so isn't
that a form of racism someone to say to
you you can't think like that you're you
know you must think like this a white
person telling you i've had it all my
life you know it's the left tend to
think that being an ethnic minority i
have to vote for left-wing parties i
have to hold left-wing opinions you know
this whole idea that we're being that
we're all one homogeneous group of
non-white people explain being i think
blackened minority ethnic or bipoc in
the us this idea that anyone that's not
white belongs to one homogeneous group
and they almost vote like think alike
and talk alike i find that racist that's
very patronizing because we're
individuals and we all have different
opinions different thoughts different
religions
why should we subscribe to the left's
narrative on what we think and i think
it comes down to control and power
because if the left say we are the party
for your particular demographic you have
to stay in that box and anyone in that
box has to for us that's how they get
into power
but how has this narrative been able to
infiltrate the church of england
well
the bishops are very i use the word
metropolitan liberal lead because i
think that's true they are
all white middle class people who are in
an echo chamber of people around them
that think alike and talk alike
therefore they're not exposed to
different thoughts and opinions
therefore they have a moral a sense of
moral superiority and it's not rooted in
scripture it's not rooted in the
religion it's rooted in their politics
they think they can make the world a
better place
with their narrow-minded perspective and
anyone that speaks up against it is cast
aside or silenced or shoved out
and
it's not representative you know the
people in the pews the people in the
congregations are small c conservative
but for the most part because this
country is small seed conservative for
the most part uh most of the clergymen
are mostly conservative some of them
aren't that's fine a good mix but the
bishops
they are the gatekeepers
and they choose who gets let in and who
doesn't get let in
something to answer to they've got no
accountability
so what have you done as a result
i just exposed it just you know i
i gave all of the emails and documents
from my subject access request that
shows the bishops
um campaigning against me i sent it all
to my friends at the
mail on sunday in the express and said
you know run with it take whatever angle
you like just put the truth out there
and they have done and i don't think the
bishops have liked it but it's opened a
lot of people's eyes to what's going on
in the church so let's go into that i'm
trying to understand what is going on in
the church and i saw a video of you
talking about
how the church is less interested in
promoting jesus but more interested in
promoting other types of woke religions
right um so
break that down for me what is the
church focusing on now rather than jesus
they've forgotten about jesus so you're
much more likely to hear a sermon on
climate change
man-made climate change
yeah oh gosh yeah all the time brexit
and how evil it is trump even though
it's nothing to do with clergy in the
church of england um
the bishops stood out they spoke out
against these things they spoke out
against dominic cummings the government
adviser they spoke out against brexit
they
kind of moralized the vaccines said to
be a good christian you have to take
this vaccine the coveted vaccine of
course the one that doesn't work um
and i think that's inappropriate and i
think that's harmful because it's
breaking down trust in an institution
that had a lot of people's trust and was
supposed to be there to support people
you know
talking about the pandemic the church
went above and beyond the uk
government's advice and closed all the
churches not just to the faithful
masters not just to people who were lost
and looking for hope during a scary time
but they closed them to the priests too
it said you can't even go in there to
pray for your parishioners i think
that's a great evil that's a great
wickedness that will take a lot of
people a long time to get over
yeah the pope was even pushing the
vaccine um and i'm not as religious as
you i'd say i'm spiritual in some ways
um
but from from a spiritual standpoint i
felt that the coercion
um just felt morally wrong
and the lies felt morally wrong
you know i'm all about freedom and i
think people should have the right to um
be free to worship which i think that
was sort of shut down last easter and
then 2021 so um
how how could how can they how can the
church justify
that
level of
sort of the lack of ethics there i think
you're right freedom of choice is the
key we should have the freedom of choice
not for freedom of worship but also for
freedom of choosing to take a vaccine if
we don't believe that the vaccine has a
good efficacy and i don't think it does
then we should have a choice whether we
take it or not and we've seen cathedrals
say you can only come to services if you
are vaccinated that you have to show a
vaccine path to get into god's house
that does not seem appropriate you know
jesus christ would be among the lepers
but people who are on backs aren't
lepers they're just people who've made
an ethical choice
um i think that you know people keep
showing me
profile pages from the wef website that
the archbishop of canterbury is amongst
them oh no um so i think there is a
clear bias there that needs addressing
i think what's kind of frightening is
the church of england for just for some
context for this i don't know is
obviously one of the oldest institutions
um in the united kingdom um and so how
has this
left-wing woke culture being able to
infiltrate that and also
how dangerous is that for just the
united kingdom at large it's systematic
so just like with every other public
body they've taken over through the long
march of institut through the
institutions so we've got key positions
being taken over in the church of
england we had
one woman who was responsible for
selecting all the bishops so it used to
be a long time ago that you know the
queen or the the lord the more the
monarchy selected the bishops
but then the monarchy became
constitutional so the prime minister
selected the bishops and put their names
forward to the queen who just signed it
off but then with gordon brown not being
a church of england uh member himself
didn't want that responsibility so he
took a step back and it became a civil
servant's job to select the bishops that
civil servant was left-leaning
metropolitan liberal elite and became
the gatekeeper and now we have a whole
house of bishops that think alike
what are the dangers of a church which
focuses on climate change trump
equality and quote unquote equality
rather than jesus
well it's it's found a new religion the
religion of woke and the dangers of that
is that when people need help when
people need to know that jesus christ is
there for them throughout their
suffering when people need someone to
look out for their spiritual well-being
when we're locked away and isolated and
lonely or people are dying without
seeing their loved ones when they need
that support it's not there for them
because the church is preaching about
other things it's got a new focus and
you know people say if you knew all this
if you knew the church's work why were
you joining it well i i believe that
this church is christ's body on earth
and i think that's an important thing
and i wanted to help at least be a part
of a moment to drag the church back
towards christ and towards the bible but
i've realized i can't do that from
within
what does this mean then for um issues
which
which the church would usually take a
stance on like homosexuality abortion
what does that mean what's the stance
now yeah so people seem to think the
church has changed its stance on these
issues but what's actually happened is
the church has stopped teaching about
these issues they stopped talking about
these issues you know there's still
christian doctrine that marriage is
between one man and one woman and it
always will because it's in the bible
they can't change that however they've
stopped having the conversation so
people think oh well the church is
lackadaisical about this anyone can you
know do whatever they like now and
that's not the case it's still the case
that the christian doctrine promotes sex
within marriage for example um
again people think oh you can you know
you sleep with her you want them that's
fine all of these things have become
non-issues abortion
the church should be arguing in favor of
pro-life and protecting the the life of
the unborn child
again people think that the church has
shifted its stance on that it hasn't on
any of them it can't on any of them
because they are biblical scriptural
there are people within the church who
want to see it change they want
homosexual marriage they want pro-choice
or pro-abortion and they want uh
promiscuity but these things aren't
christian tenants so they cannot have
them how far do you think this is gonna
go
it could go you know at the moment the
church is having a big conversation
about homosexual marriage for example
and when i bring this up let me just
make be clear i'm not against
homosexuality i'm not against gay people
i'm just saying that a christian
marriage is between one man and one
woman united on the eyes of god for the
purposes of procreation and
and go forth and multiply and all of
that it's not to say that some other
people in different lifestyles are bad
people or wrong people or should be
ostracized everybody should be welcomed
in the church i just want to make that
clear because people think when you're
promoting one thing it means you're
against another and that's not always
the case
but it's very very clear what the
christian stance of these issues is
so let's go into this whole woke
narrative because i i feel you know it's
clearly infiltrated the church of
england um it's infiltrating even even
you know even something is ridiculous
like netflix you know you can't watch a
movie without feeling um like you're
being indoctrinated by something um so
i've heard people say the reason
we now have this woke church
um it's sort of become a religion and
the reason why they have that is because
there's a lack of religion
um you know society's become so secular
and people feel like they lack purpose
you know religion sort of grounded them
um what are your thoughts on that why do
you think people are becoming so woke
100 people need something that people
have a void in their lives and they're
looking for meaning and the church
hasn't been there to step in and say
here we are you know christ is with you
so the church has taken a step back and
in fact closed its doors so people have
looked elsewhere people have joined blm
protests or extinction rebellion or
glued their faces to the floor
or you know attacked police horses and
joined these groups because they have a
sense of belonging and it's the same
with a lot of issues we're seeing so you
know the whole trans debate the reason
we've seen so many people suddenly come
out as trans when it used to be such a
small minority it's because the moment
you say you are trans you've got a
family you've got a community you've got
a whole cohort of people there to
support you you feel like you belong to
something it's a movement and now you
don't even have to do anything
physically you just identify as well so
it's so much easier to gain entry into
that community
it's so true
um if you identify as a victim
then you get all this attention and all
this love
that's all people want a bit of love
it's mind-blowing i think um what's
interesting you mentioned blm
so i'm guessing
you don't like blm or you don't believe
in um the i'm sure you believe in the
slogan but you don't believe in no i
don't believe in slogan i think the
slogan is problematic black lives matter
what does that mean does that mean black
lives matter more than white lives does
that mean that why do why black lives in
particular why not jewish lives matter
why not arabic lives matter
surely all lives matter is the first
logo
please there is no police brutality in
the uk and if there is
it's mostly our males it's not any
particular uh racial demographic we've
imported u.s politics in that the u.s
can handle their own business someone
will get involved in that that's their
thing but for people over here to be
protesting to defund the police and that
black lives matter seems very confused
to me
yeah that's something which actually
upset me during the riots because i
think in the uk we're very racially
diverse everybody's all sort of just get
on here
um and then when the riots were
happening in america
we started protesting here
black and white people going at it and
i'm like this is not how it happens in
britain black and white people don't go
at it here i mean yesterday was
ascension day in the uk
we celebrated it in the church
and the guy giving the uh
saying the prayers in my church said i
want to say a special prayer to remember
george floyd
i'm thinking this guy he wasn't a saint
he's like it's almost been canonized as
and held up on a pedestal the guy was a
criminal he was a convict and he was a
pretty bad guy in the way he treated his
his baby mother and the drugs and the
gun and all that stuff
i understand it was horrible what
happened to him but let's not pretend he
was some kind of hero let's not pretend
he was a martyr and that's what
to again to bring that u.s politics over
here where i'm sat in a uk church a
church of england church hearing someone
preaching about george floyd it just it
riles me up how much support do you get
when you talk about these things
a lot of support
uh a lot of quiet sports a lot of dms
emails and letters people saying thank
you for saying what you say i can't say
it because i get fired
oh that's awful that happens that's
crazy people feel like they're oppressed
and they are because
it seems in the mainstream media in
politics all across the the public
square the woke opinions are the ones
you hear but it's very small minority
they're just a very vocal minority most
people don't believe in that nonsense
most i believe that most people in this
country believe in common sense and
british values but they're afraid to
speak up because if they stick their
head above the parapet it might get
chopped off to what extent do you feel
that you have to identify with a certain
political party or a narrative based on
the colour of your skin
uh i don't i just i ignore all that
rubbish but i people want me to people
want me to say
every time i speak up people either say
thank you for doing that and encouraging
me and i i agree with you or
you're a grifter you know who's either
you're you're pirating what the white
master wants you to say or
you're you're just making this up for
clicks and views or it cannot possibly
be that these are my opinions and these
this is my lived experience and these
are always the people that are all
talking about this is you know let's
hear more lived experiences it's always
the people that are saying let's listen
to more ethnic minority voices but they
don't want to hear them if they
contradict what they're saying i believe
in what i'm saying i see what i mean and
i mean what i say i think everyone
should do that but it really really gets
on my nerves when people assume that
these aren't my opinions because why
that's racism i can't hold these
opinions because i happen to have brown
skin that's your issue not mine it's
funny it's like modern day racism of
course it is but they don't see it
how would you
how do you feel
we go about changing that
because these people won't listen to you
no
yeah because feelings have replaced
facts haven't they and it's all about
how someone feels and their anecdotal
experience i know i've used the term
lived experience so so often but that
just means an anecdote it means their
personal anecdotes they are weighted
more heavily than evidence facts data
statistics and we need to flip that back
around and say actually if we want to
make society a better place we have to
look at the big picture
we have to be evidence informed we have
to look at what's actually going on
and that's the only way we can solve
these problems if we only listen to the
loudest voices we're not looking at
where the issue is
what i'm trying to understand is you
mentioned it's all about control earlier
um let's um let's get into that what do
you mean it's about control who's
controlling what and what are they
trying to control so for example when
joe biden says if you don't vote
democrat you ain't black that's so bad
of course it's bad i mean we recognize
that's probably quite racist yeah but
the left would say actually yes because
the democrats are the party for black
people and the way they do that is that
that's a whole demographic of people
that must vote for their party in order
to get them into power it's the same
over here with jeremy corbyn who said we
will unlock your potential as ethnic
minorities i don't need a politician to
unlock my potential thank you very much
i work hard and i believe in meritocracy
and i'll get by on my own and i think on
the right we tend to believe in a hand
up not a handout you know helping
someone help themselves yes on the left
it's more collectivism it's more the
state is responsible for you and you
you're dependent on the state and the
state therefore must help you
and i think that's it's condescending
because it holds people down it holds
people back and this whole victimhood
mentality is all that you know if we
tell people often enough that they are a
victim they'll start to believe it
they'll start to act like a victim and
then they'll get stuck in a rut and
you'll say and then you can say look
these black people are victims it's like
well yes because you've spent so long
telling them they are that they're no
longer trying to get out of this rut
so i totally agree with you and joe
biden also said something which really
annoyed me as a female he said something
like i will be the one to help women
i'm like why do women need help we're
good
isn't that kind of just like such a
godly mentality that he has of himself
to think that he's the savior of women
and or whatever it is um
so yeah for me for me that's it's such a
such a bizarre way of doing things um
but
they tell okay so the democrats the left
you know they preach that
certain minorities or certain groups are
victims
do you think they genuinely think that
they're victims or do you think and i
personally think this is the democrats
they tell them victims so that they can
stay as victims and they stay under the
boot it's a bit of both people like joe
biden i think he knows what he's doing
if we look at things he's said in the
past he's been quite racist on a lot of
occasions however interestingly if you
show people clips of what he said
they'll back him up unless you take his
face off it and play them the audio clip
that's racist
so there's a there's a bias going on
there
but there's two types of people there's
one type of person that
is genuinely wanting to help people but
is misguided and thinks that the left's
approach is the right way and then
there's the more malicious person who
wants to keep people oppressed wants to
keep people but down because if people
are dependent on you
then that you're they're going to give
you their vote for example the whole the
whole welfare state system is set up so
that you know if you are dependent on
the state to give you your paycheck of
course you're going to vote for the
party that's going to give you the
biggest paycheck that's just common
sense
so it's it's detrimental to people's
well-being you know people want
naturally to contribute people want to
be
leading meaningful lives they don't want
to be stuck at home watching tv all day
waiting for the next welfare check
that's not natural
so
it's not natural but do you think
i see my thing is i think by design
humans always take the path of least
resistance
and so that's why we're in the situation
that we're in because people
don't want to go back to work after
getting you know their stimulus checks
or their furlough
so i'm in like this two minds of of you
know people do want to feel empowered
and i do think you know when you make
your own money and you're empowered and
you're feeling good you're eating
healthy you're feeling great
everything's going really well in your
life that's when you're most happiest
but i don't think people want to put in
the work that will make you most
happiest because we like to take the
path of least resistance yeah it's not
in their interest to do so right so i
often talk about the reason i'm a
conservative because my mother was a
single parent
raising me and my sister on her own
working multiple jobs to feed us but she
would have been better off at home a lot
of her friends were at home on benefits
they were making more money than she was
but she wanted to contribute she wanted
to show me that working hard is how you
get by and i'm so thankful that she did
that because that's where i got my work
ethic from but it wouldn't make sense
for her to do it and like i say most
people didn't why would you put the
extra effort in if you're better off not
doing it that's why the welfare state is
criminal i totally agree with you um and
it's so funny because people often say
that's so heartless
um but i think the heartless thing is is
making someone dependent on you and not
teaching them how to save themselves
it's a misunderstanding of heartlessness
and kindness you know as a teacher i
often experience this
i'm a strong disciplinarian i think if a
child is misbehaving you give them a
disciplinary measure you give them an
attention or something and people say
you know if they're coming from a
deprived background or they're an ethnic
minority or something you can't expect
them to do the same amounts of homework
you know they've got issues going on at
home they've got a hard life be a bit
more relaxed with them and like actually
that no that's not a kindness that's
holding them back because if you say oh
poor jimmy you don't have to do your
homework because you've got a hard
situation you know your dad's left your
mom and your mum's drinking if you go
down that route then let jimmy off from
his homework he doesn't reach the same
levels as the rest of his classmates
he's so you're literally holding him
back so he's he's getting less knowledge
than everyone else therefore he's less
empowered when he leaves school to get a
good job and to make a good life for
himself
what feels like a kindness is actually
that is heartlessness to when you truly
love someone you give them you tell them
the truth or you give them boundaries
that's what love is love is a kindness
in
in a in a boundary and a bounded
structure of support it's not about
giving people the freedom to destroy
themselves tough love yeah tough love
yeah warm strict yeah yeah
what other areas do you feel that um
wokism is um
infiltrating um you know you mentioned
trans
um so that's like gender now we have
more than uh two genders um i know
you've spoken about meat
so
what other areas do you feel like the
wokism is uh infiltrating it's
everywhere it's everywhere we look it's
tiring sometimes like just living a
normal life everywhere you go is
wokeness you know
in the church you walk in the church
sometimes you've got the rainbow flag on
the altar now instead of a cross
you go into schools it's the same
situation and they're saying you know
young boys can wear skirts now as well
as well as the girls because they don't
want to offend anybody um tell me an
issue of an area of life and i'll tell
you where the workless is because it's
everywhere okay so you spoke about meat
um i saw an interview did recently you
were talking about you went to this talk
or something in oxford where they
compared me to meat to white supremacy
can you just explain that for us so that
was michaela peterson debating this
i'm trying to be charitable here this
woman
let's just use her uh her
that adjective because i don't want to
use anything else because i'm just
according to ad hominems this person was
talking about
so michael and peterson obviously she
has a meat-eating diet she's a big
carnivore and it's fantastic it works
for her this other person was saying
that uh we should all give up meat
because meat is racist
sexist
colonialist
um i can't remember what other histories
and she said i i had to walk out i just
couldn't stomach it because at some
point you have to say look this is not a
debate in good faith this is
there's nothing we can debate with here
because this is pure lunacy and i'm not
going to entertain it i'm done with you
um i spoke to jordan peterson about it
afterwards because he was laughing
because obviously he could see me just
storm out
he said you know i would have done the
same but i was supporting michaela but
i think we just have to say to these
people i'm not going to engage with your
linus anymore that is you know you're on
a different plane that's ridiculous
there is no point that we can there's no
common ground we can meet on here
but they do believe it though so what
i'm trying to understand i'm trying to
understand the rationale right do they
believe it though or are they trying to
tick every box because they think oh
we're in a university campus excuse me
we're in university campus we'll talk
about racism we'll talk about sexism
we'll talk about colonialism we'll talk
about the other isms and this and then
everyone will love us is it about
wanting people to like you
some people genuinely believe it
otherwise we won't be at this point i
mean i personally think i mean people
might call me a conspiracy theorist
that's cool
but i personally think it's because meat
gives you strength right
meat is good protein and helps you build
muscle and you know keeps you strong and
fit and when you're strong and fit
you can fight yeah yeah fight whatever
it is whether it's so they don't want us
to fight back because yes yeah
you ever thought about that no that's
deep
i don't believe in the term conspiracy
theorist anymore by the way because the
conspiracy theories over the last two
years have been spoiler alerts and it
will come true
so what do you think about that then i
mean there must be a reason why they're
bright and because it's not it's not
just me you're not giving them too much
credit no i don't think they're smarter
than they are well i don't think it
comes from the woman who was debating
michaela i think it comes from a higher
place perhaps yes perhaps claus schwab
type world economic forum places um
because you know by 2030 you'll have
your or you'll have nothing and be happy
i won't though i wish we had a second
amendment like what they have in the
united states a way to protect ourselves
from these terraneous
dictators well let's talk about that
because um recently by the time this
airs the unfortunate shooting that
happened in texas will be a few weeks
ago now um but that's interesting as a
british person you feel that you would
like
the right to bear arms yeah it's
biblical you know christ said to his
apostles
get yourself a sword
he said if you don't have one sell it
sell your robes get yourself a sword
i think
do you think that would work here
here in the uk it's a different issue
but
we used to have the right to bear arms
i mean it was still until quite recently
the law that we had to practice uh bow
and arrow shooting just in case to
protect the nation but we have to have a
way of protecting ourselves from the
state and i worry about that especially
over the last couple of years the way
that the whole west or the western world
some including you know new zealand and
australia in this the way they've
gone back on civil liberties and decided
that actually governments have the power
to control your personal life you know
we used to say an englishman's home is
his castle it's up to me who i invite
into my house but no not anymore the
government could say actually you only
allowed so many people in your house
you're not allowed to touch them you
can't hug your loved ones you can't go
outside of your house or if you can only
for once a day and only for five minutes
or whatever that is too much no
government should have that much say
over someone's life
and if they're willing to do that over
something that is essentially a cold or
a flu what are they willing to do for
worse situations
and is this a test run for something
else i don't know i'm stepping into what
i said i don't believe in conspiracy
theories but i'm stepping into that
ground now because
until two years ago i never thought in
my wildest dreams that something like
that would happen that we'd follow the
ideology of communist china and i know
that italy did it first and we'll say we
copied to italy but we're essentially
copying china
why we if we believe that they are a
great evil if we believe that they are a
force to be reckoned with in this world
and we should be fighting against their
values why are we copying them
i totally agree with you um i'm gonna
we're gonna get into all of that
actually um
but i wanna go i wanna focus a little
bit more on the right to protect
yourself
um
because how do we protect ourselves here
in the uk i mean even in the us guns
didn't protect them from
medicine mandates i don't like to hit
the red flag on the algorithm with the
words so medicine medicine mandates um
guns didn't protect them so how do we
protect ourselves from tyrannical
governments
how do we i suppose it's all about
numbers isn't it
we have to remember that we are the
majority we have to stand up saying that
you know in the uk we had the biggest
protest ever against the war in iraq and
it still went ahead tony blair still
went ahead with that war even though the
vast majority people didn't want it so
i'm not i'm not sure if a majority even
works anymore i have honestly no idea
how we stop these these things it's i
lose sleep over it it's the idea that
there are a group of elites meeting in
davos right now as we record this
deciding our fates and a lot of people
think we're crazy for believing that but
you know they literally published their
ideas
this monkey pops nonsense for example
last year there was a a war game
set up what if monkey pox becomes the
next pandemic and they a war game like
an actual like on the playstation i
think like global leaders got together
to plan what what they do if monkey box
walking like they play play it out they
sit there around the table like a like
um what the
pretend uh thing is called um
and if you look at the timetable they
said it would drop in what was it um may
2022 and i mean the timeline hit with
what we're seeing now and that we we see
everywhere in the press at the moment is
this monkey pop situation which the
symptoms aren't as severe as smallpox
it's very closely linked to chickenpox
as well in fact it's the same vaccine
for monkeybox and smallpox
and the numbers we're seeing are
negligible but then media is reporting
it so heavily and we've got bill gates
came out a year ago saying you know um a
pox might be the next pandemic and next
time we'll take it more seriously and
next time governments will have to
restrict liberties sooner and faster and
harder as i'm like if these leaders are
saying this and they're predicting this
and it's all coming true bear in mind
smallpox has been eradicated for what 70
years or so
and suddenly we've got a version of that
coming out after the elites have
predicted that particular
virus spreading amongst us all of these
things can't always become instances
do you think that um these elites world
governments world economic forum do you
think that they overplayed their hand
throughout covert
i think they've got away with it
throughout covert i think there's still
a vast majority of people in this
country are because people are invested
in that in the in the the medicine that
they took now so people have to believe
that it worked even though the fires a
data drop showed that actually it wasn't
95 efficacy it was 12 efficacy and after
like a week it went down to one percent
so the thing doesn't work it doesn't do
anything at best at worst it has more
adverse effects than any other vaccine
we've ever issued uh in our recorded
history
uh you know they tried it with tamiflu
in 2009 but thankfully at that point the
media called it out and said this virus
isn't spreading as rapidly it's not as
dangerous and the vaccine for it doesn't
work therefore this is a major scam by
the pharmaceutical industry and because
the media called it out it got halted
this time around the government got on
the phone to the media um and gave them
words of cash uh called it uh
what was the word for it uh some kind of
supplement to it to support them um
throughout a lockdown and all that
situation so the media were funded
directly by the government and this the
officials were not on the phone while
the prime minister was calling around
the major um news corporations and you
know i've worked i work in the news and
i've seen the conversations that i had
and the topics that you're not allowed
to discuss at the same time they change
the offcom ruling
ofcom is the independent body which
regulates the media over here
to what offcom said you can no longer
question or undermine public health
policy you can no longer question it
what that's outrageous and you know on
certain radio stations that i used to
frequent
the lawyer said look just don't touch
the topic
what radio station i'm not gonna name
them but these are ones that we would
think are fighting on on our side lbc
probably
if if the lawyers
are that protective because they don't
want to get shut down so who is who is
fighting for the general people who is
who's on our side you and i
alternative news oh yeah joe rogan yeah
yeah um okay so i tried to shut him down
exactly and elon musk
what happened when elon musk said we'll
fight for free speech all of these uh
these instances come out of apparent
sexual abuse and like oh that's
coincidence interesting timing he
predicted it
um you said you don't know how
we solved this and you said it keeps you
up at night so for those that don't know
the way that you and i met was through
twitter and we were talking um because
because of everything that was going on
in canada when justin trudeau um he had
his medicine mandates and the truckers
were protesting and i was very vocal
because bitcoin
and i don't mean to be a cliche honestly
um but for me i agree with everything
that you said and for me and for my
community
we truly believe that bitcoin is the
solution because it's all about money
right you even said it you said that the
government gave the media money
so it's all about the money to start off
with
you will owe nothing and be happy
because they'll own everything the money
so if you don't own if
if they don't have control over the
money then they lose control
so to what extent do you have a
knowledge about bitcoin thank you for
not saying bitcoin fixes this
well we'll get that we'll get there
calvin
i do think it is part of the solution
decentralized money and decentralized
power go hand in hand
this whole idea that the government
wants a digital central currency
uh where they can essentially control
where we spend our money is the most
dangerous thing i can think of the bank
of england says we need to have the
power to prevent people spending money
in the wrong places we need to have the
control the wrong places exactly oh what
meat for example meat is not good for
you it's carcinogenic you cannot buy
meat and that's it you're done
green causes uh you can't buy plane
tickets because it's bad for the
environment of course the elite will
still swung around in the private jets
as we've seen they're all flying to
davos to talk about climate change it's
the hypocrisy but
yeah i think bitcoin could help us along
the way it's a good test case
but does it have
that grassroots movement to get going
into you know
you can sit around and talk about it
quite
eloquently and articulate it very well
on your podcast but if i was to say to
my grandmother
bitcoin it fixes this would i be able to
put that across in a way that she would
understand do you know what i mean it's
got to be like i just paid i got a cab
here i paid the guy in cash and he was
like so thankful that i gave him cash
and not tried to use a card but that's
how we keep these things alive but
everyone understands cash we understand
that it's a promise of payment and that
we don't have to go into the into the
whole fiat system but we get that
handing over that note means that i have
a tangible amount that i can cash in as
a bank
somebody say something really
cold-hearted go on um just because i i'm
into the facts okay so elon musk said
something really interesting and he said
um i can't i'm gonna try paraphrase i
can't fully remember but it was
something like
he said like death is good because
without the death of the older
generation
we wouldn't change and we wouldn't
innovate right
that's what he was saying so because if
everyone stayed alive and the older
generation remains nothing would change
because you get to a certain age whereby
you're set in your ways you can't teach
an old dog new tricks um you know in the
bitcoin community we laugh at warren
buffett because he just can't understand
bitcoin and it's it's funny um and so
that's why it's the younger generation
who are more open-minded and open to
change that are able to bring about
these new things now the interesting
thing is the fact that you and i are
talking the reason that's interesting is
because you're from the politics sphere
although i'm super into politics i'm
from the bitcoin sphere but we're
meeting for a reason yeah
it's because our worlds are colliding
and so i think it's people like you who
are going to bring about the next
bitcoin revolution and the next adoption
of bitcoin okay
i do worry about that i know you said
you were going to be cold-hearted and
you know you're playing it off a bit but
i do worry about that because
it's the older generations that hold us
back a bit and that's important because
we can't progress too quickly and as
much as i love elon musk for being a
free speech absolutist and i hope he
does buy twitter i know he's playing
games with him at the moment but if he
does it'd be great
but he's also a massive liberal a
massive liberal progressive
i don't agree with his politics you know
he he would be he would be big into
transhumanism for example and i think
that's a dangerous line and i think
actually
he'd probably have a lot in common with
the wef lot on that on that front as in
they can't wait for us to all be shipped
in some way or another it's another form
of control and he sees it as exciting
and innovative and people like that you
know he's well intentioned but people
like that are what lead us down a
straight path so we do have to be
careful and not this is why i don't hear
a worship as much as i think it's
fantastic what he's doing in some ways
we have to be so careful on the speed at
which we process progress not just in
trans transhumanism but also in
artificial intelligence
and all of these areas of
digital digital world which is why
having the older generation say actually
no i just want to use my five pound note
to buy my pack of [ __ ] cigarettes for
the americans nothing
that's such a good thing that's such a
novelty
no i understand and i agree with you um
and that's funny because i think there's
a meme online which is like bill gates
wants to put a chip in your brain no way
elon musk yeah let's have a chip in my
brain
yeah because yeah he i do believe he is
well intentioned um but no i'm totally
with you but i don't think bitcoin is
that
no no it's not
you know and i think that
i've spoken to a lot of different people
um who are quite conservative in the uk
and they they tend to be interested in
bitcoin but i do think it's it's you
guys who are going to bring about the
next grassroots as you put it because
you have the libertarians you have the
people like myself who are very
interested in bitcoin the bitcoiners
um but as more things happen like justin
trudeau freezes people's bank accounts
because they don't want to take certain
medicines
people like you i do believe we'll drive
we'll drive the next we'll push the next
wave well that's very kind i think it
comes down to convenience so the the
analogy i always look at is you know i
spent a lot of time in america and i i
know you're going there soon and it's
just over there is very different over
here and the way that we pay for pay for
things the transactions are different so
i'm always surprised when i go to the
west coast
and how difficult it is to just use my
card or you know just to swipe or my my
phone often in the uk i know i'm a big
supporter of cash but often i can leave
my house with just my phone and not be
stressed because i know that i can get
on a bus and get a taxi and go in the
shop and buy a chocolate bar i can go to
a cafe buy a drink and go out to a
restaurant i do whatever i like i can go
clothes shopping and i just go
in america it's so difficult for some
reason the people that invented all this
technology just they're so reticent and
it's taken them a long time you know
things like square have come around and
then there was apple pay but only in
certain places and it's like what are
you doing it just feels so backwards but
of course that like you know
the rate of progress is important but
over why i'm talking about that is
because with bitcoin
there isn't that element of convenience
i can't just nip into my local shop and
say can i just wire you bitcoin there's
there needs to be a jump there that it
makes it easier for the shopkeeper and
easier for the person coming in
or more convenient for them to use
bitcoin than it did to pull out a
five-point note and the mobile phone or
the contact list is more convenient and
that's why they're winning on that front
but bitcoin isn't quite at that place
yet yeah i do agree with you i think
that um it's all about convenience
people would sacrifice democracy and all
that stuff for convenience it's yeah
it's the
lifelong tell um the community is
working on it and there are different
things that you can do um there are
different intermediaries i mean you
mentioned square
there's cash app um in america which
actually accepts bitcoin um so there's
loads of different things but i don't
know i just sort of think like
politically as from like a decentralized
standpoint as the world becomes more
authoritarian i mean you mentioned
cbdc's central bank digital currencies
um and actually at the world economic
forum um in davos i think it was this
week um
so they were talking about them and
somebody actually said i don't know who
was but she was on stage she actually
said if we do implement this like china
have done
um if we do implement this then we're
going to need a new human rights bill
okay to ensure because because of the
tyrannical potential yeah so then the
question is who's to say that they'll
stick to that the same way they didn't
stick to the nuremberg code when it came
to the vaccines oh absolutely well they
won't do because it won't be in their
interest will it so what protection do
we have it comes back to
how do we protect ourselves from the
state and i still don't have the answer
to that bitcoin is the answer i'm sorry
yeah okay if bitcoin fixes it show me
how i'm i'm i'm open to the idea that
bitcoin does fix it i'm just not seeing
it yet yeah i mean because i i am a
supporter of the second amendment um
that we we uh touched on earlier um it's
just like because everything's becoming
digital it's like to what extent are
guns going to be helpful like i said in
new york it didn't really help them well
the israelis do tend to have a better
idea around that than the americans i
think you know the israelis did you
think yeah
in what way as in you know the teachers
will have guns in the security guards oh
i see yeah
there are other approaches yeah but i
mean like that didn't protect them from
uh
the green card you had to have in it and
yeah
so
with all of that in mind um you know my
answer is bitcoin um where do you think
we go from here in terms of
you know what culture infiltrating the
church of england
um you know meat being this this this
white supremacy type of food you know
where do you think we go from here um we
just all have to start speaking up and i
think you're right in that bitcoin for
example
you mentioned canada a few times
when they started blocking the bank
accounts of the protesters and then we
saw the bitcoin people saying well you
know we can donate via brick coins so
that was a great solution so coming up
with positive solutions to help the
problems that we're facing is good but
in general
just normal everyday folk need to not be
afraid of being cancelled you need to
stand up whether it's saying no i enjoy
a stake and i'm not a white supremacist
there are two genders man and woman and
you know i know the truth you can lie to
my face but that's your issue not mine
um or whether it's saying that you know
as a white person i'm not a pr an
oppressor as a black person i'm not a
victim i just own the truth and just
speak up and if you know they cannot
cancel all of us
i'm also interested in the fact that um
just sort of going back a sec you didn't
come from a religious background
um so i'm interested i know you sort of
said that your mum and seeing her work
hard is what gave you that um i guess
that conservative mindset of
working hard and wanting to build
something um
but where does the religious part come
in
i think i've always had
a knowledge of god that he existed i
think we're all born with that i think
we all have some innate
gut instinct that is something bigger
than ourselves
um
some people deny it some people silence
it and push it aside but i think we all
we're all born with that it's linked to
our to our instinct it's linked to our
conscience
um
but it took me a long long time to find
religion and it was only when i found it
when i found the faith
that i realized that's what i've always
been searching for
um
to articulate it in in a way that people
might feel uncomfortable with but
it was only when i had an experience
with christ that i realized that he's
the one i've been searching for my whole
life
and that was special for me and that
changed my whole outlook on life and
made me decide that actually
i need to center my life around christ
and so my politics comes from that my
work comes from that everything i do
comes from that at least i try to
live a christian life as best i can
i'm interested because um
religion is very much about faith
right
um arguably maybe you could tell me i'm
wrong but it's not so much facts it's
faith
um and you and you know how
being a conservative we're more
interested in facts over feelings
um so how do you navigate life
with christ at the center of it
but you know you're
you're basing you're basing your life
off of faith rather than facts so i see
them as the same thing so i see the
problem with the left is that
everything's become subjective so
everything everyone owns their own
individual truths everyone creates their
own realities and expects all of us to
live in their reality which is actually
a fantasy it's not a reality
um when someone says they're gender
fluid or that they are now identifying
as a horse
i don't see that as an objective truth i
see that as their subjective fantasy
whereas within the faith we're giving
we're given a book
that is directed by god is the word of
god himself and that is an objective
truth
that should shape
our reality and we should be focusing on
heading towards you so even if you're
not christian i talk about you know the
enlightenment is the pursuit of
knowledge
and as a christian we have the pursuit
of the universal truth and jesus christ
said he was the way the truth and the
life
so we're looking to center everything
around him so it's an anchor it's a
point that you can always draw to and if
someone says actually this is the truth
now you say no i've still got it it's
it's it's fixed it's static it's
objective
okay
and
like i said i
don't call myself a religious person but
i would definitely say i'm spiritual
because what does that mean
it means that i believe in a higher
power
um and i don't know what i would call it
so i don't know if i would call it god
the universe
um but i definitely believe in like a
kind loving energy
um
so my my question is like how are you so
sure
that god is real
because i've had experiences where i
have been touched in my heart by god
i've felt his presence
um
and when i read the bible it reads true
to me
but i think it's so important the path
that you're on i mean we all have our
own faith journeys but when you say you
believe in a faith or you believe in a
power bigger than others i think that
just that starting point is so important
because that's something i find that on
the left many on the left the work
people don't have
and it's a sense of accountability it's
a sense of
we are not the most important thing in
the universe
i think in their in their eyes they
often are whereas we would say that
there's something bigger than us and
that's more important whether that's
community or god you know having that
sense of
of otherness
it's grounding it's it's a humanity
and you said it's because you've had
experiences do you think that's because
you are chosen in some way or do you
think it's or do you think you're just
spiritually more open
i don't know like why do you have your
experience versus somebody else like why
don't i say i feel
my heart has been touched by god like
why do you say that i suppose it's just
you haven't needed it
that's but what happens in our lives
directs us down a path and sometimes we
need a bit of a kick up the back side
and sometimes we don't and you might be
on a journey to get to where you need to
be without need without any prompting
or there might be something that happens
later in your life that prompts you and
you and
opens your eyes to god um i can't i
can't really comment on that but my own
personal experience is that
whenever i've needed god whenever i've
said prayers for something those prayers
have been answered or at least i've felt
that they've been answered and that's
been important to me
that's really interesting i'm always
interested to hear people's perspective
on god and i know because obviously you
center your life around um the religion
so
what so what are you doing now
essentially um i know you're at gb news
um when will you become a priest are you
still becoming a priest i will um at gb
news i'm launching a new show on faith
and family nice very soon hopefully
congrats thank you um and i'll be
ordained next month and i'll be a priest
in um well the gaffcom movement which is
growing in north america it's much
smaller over here what does that stand
for um well it's the global anglican's
future conference but it's about being
an orthodox anglican so i would say you
know people say why have you left the
church of england i would say the church
of england has left me
i i think it's left the faith behind and
addressed a new new religion but there
are lots of anglicans around the world
that hold dear to the anglican formulas
of you know the bible and the book of
common prayer and the 39 articles so i'm
joining their group
being validly ordained
i'm going to set up a church in london
very very soon and you're welcome to
come along i will do um yeah so i'm
going to get on with my public ministry
on gv news and my parish ministry in
london that's amazing major congrats on
all of that um do you would you say part
of that um in any way is maybe
in any way do you feel like you would
like to
undo the woke
the woke-ism that's infiltrated the
united kingdom do you feel like that's
something you're now going to dedicate a
little bit of time to as a priest
no it's too tiring it's it's draining i
think instead of trying to undo the
workness i'm trying i'm going to try at
least offer an alternative
um you know
my church will be a space that is rooted
in faith rooted in christ rooted in
objective truth and if people want to
escape the madness of the world around
them they're welcome to come here okay
amazing and where can people find you
and follow you um so i have a website
evangelical
evangelicalcatholics.com
people can put their email address in
and once the church is planted i'll let
them know uh but i'm on all the social
media platforms at calvin robinson
calvin i want to thank you so much it's
been so fascinating hearing your
perspective
and it's it's really just so refreshing
to speak to people who see reality um
and are also brave enough to speak up um
with regards to everything that's going
on at the moment well thank you keep
fighting the good fights always thank
you i'll hold you in my prayers
thank you likewise
guys thank you so much for watching if
you enjoyed this episode please don't
forget to hit the like button and hit
subscribe so you can support the channel
and you never miss a video and also a
massive thank you to our sponsors as
always bitmex and step finance because
without both of them we want to be able
to bring you such important content
we'll see you next week malaya high or
pancho
you